[Music]
the longest border in the world is kind
of strange goes on for thousands and
thousands of miles in like a straight
line and there's a bunch of weird little
details about this line that I'm
becoming quite curious about this is the
border of the United States and Canada
yeah I know to Canada videos in a row
I'm just really into Canada lately and
Canada's got some weird stuff going on
and it's kind of this like neighbor to
the north that no one ever talks about
because it's seemingly just not that
interesting but it actually is really
interesting that's what I'm here to tell
you so let's do this they're done Chris
I spent the weekend in Vancouver BC
hanging out with some friends friends
Chris and Lizzie and Becky and Chris who
are just gems of people really fun to
hang out with very talented creators is
what are we Doug - where are we what's
going down you can say it loud is he say
it loud we're gonna we're getting ramen
but I'm gonna say it - we're getting
ramen so worked out really well and
there was lots of fpv drones and while
on this trip one of the things I did
while we were driving around is what I
always do which is pull out my phone and
started looking at the map of where we
were and I just started to get really
curious about this line this straight
line that goes on for thousands of
kilometres
it's like 6,500 kilometers worth of line
on the map and I've always just ignored
this line is kind of like oh that's just
like the boring line that separates
these like two countries that are like
best friends and have no tension no
drama or nothing interesting about this
line it's just straight and boring is
what I always thought then the rabbit
holes began
there's actually some really interesting
stuff about this line like weird
enclaves and like a Skype Border Patrol
and all this stuff that I'll explain in
just a second but first let's remember
why I'm here I came to explore and to
have a good time with my friends okay so
back to this line there's a whole
history here I don't know if you're
interested in the history lesson right
now I'm not so let's just put it this
way a lot of candidate used to be owned
by the French fought some wars with
written they lost the wars and they were
kind of like Manuel just like kind of
surrender Canada
French writer Voltaire kind of hated
Canada said it was quote just a few
acres of snow so the British take over
Canada the United States is starting to
expand to the south they want to take
over tons of land they want to go north
and take over Canada but the British
don't really want them to take over
Canada and they fight and they end up
not taking over Canada and eventually
they established a line between the
north and the south that says this is
Canada and this is the United States
through a bunch of treaties they
determine exactly where the line is
going to be there's one number that
completely determined how this border
would look and that number is actually
the same name as this coffee shop that
we're in right now in Vancouver
49th parallel had this big vision of
sitting on this log I don't think it's
gonna work am i contributing to erosion
with all of this traipsing to the woods
here they go they've got a line they've
got a number the 49th parallel this is
like the 1800s they don't have GPS in
fact they don't have any precise tools
for actually measuring what that line
looks like when you're in the mountains
of Canada so they send a bunch of people
out with string they made a bunch of
straight lines that were supposed to go
along the 49th parallel and I mean they
did a pretty darn good job for just like
using string and compasses I'm actually
pretty impressed but not surprisingly if
you zoom into this very straight line
you'll see that there's actually a
little bit of a zigzagging going on the
border doesn't actually go perfectly
along the 49th parallel to demarcate the
border they put thousands of these stone
markings and then they also to make it
very clear cut a gap in the trees that's
like 20 feet wide it's kind of a bizarre
looking thing especially from space you
just see this like gap in the trees so
[Music]
by the end of it continental United
States is going to be south of the 49th
parallel and Canada would be north of
the 49th parallel this is a great thing
when you're looking wide at a map but
nature isn't super good at straight
lines which is why when we draw borders
it kind of clashes sometimes with how
the world actually works and so you get
some weird stuff first over here in
Vancouver zoom into Vancouver and you'll
see this little Peninsula this lil
Peninsula is great just like any other
Peninsula but look what happens when you
draw the 49th parallel through it this
is point Roberts
it's a little Enclave that belongs to
the United States because it's south of
the 49th parallel but you can see that
it's like should be in Canada
it's cut off from the US this little
town of like 1500 people is strange
because there are people living there
who are US citizens they belong to the
state of Washington they have a little
Elementary School in this village but
what they don't have is anything above
an elementary school so anyone who wants
to go to school has to get on a bus go
across the border into Canada all the
way around like 40 kilometers or
something like that back in the United
States go to school and then back across
into Canada and back into the United
States it's like four border crossings
in one day sounds like a nightmare
listen I know we're talking about the US
Canada border and everything but just
take a minute to look at this mossy
green forest that I'm in north of
Vancouver it's just the most magical
thing I've ever seen is everyone
convinced that Moss is the greatest
thing in the world yet on the record
yeah you've been on board since the
beginning I was on board from the begins
you're on board now hater I've got
everyone on board
[Music]
okay so back to this line keep going
down the straight line and eventually
you'll hit an area where the whole
straight line 49th parallel thing
doesn't really work as a place to draw a
border the Treaty says that as soon as
this 49th parallel hits this Lake it's
called Lake of the Woods that the border
would need to trace the northwest corner
meaning the upper-left corner of this
border and then continue onward but
there was a problem the map they were
using to draw this border was kind of
bad and inaccurate and so it made the
lake look a lot more like round and like
cleaner and like more in line with their
vision for the border but then when they
went to actually survey it they realized
that this northwest corner the upper
left was actually way up here making the
border have to go up to fulfill the
terms of the treaty and then continue
onward from there it starts to follow
rivers and it goes into the Great Lakes
and it's a little more complicated but
in the process of going up to fulfill
the treaty and hitting the upper left of
this lake you get this this little blob
of land is appropriately named the
northwest angle it's the only piece of
the continental United States
that is north of the 49th parallel
there's a couple hundred people who live
there and if they want to get in and out
of their community they have to go to
this little booth and they have to video
call like Skype the Border Patrol
- like report that they're coming in and
out and declare whatever stuff they want
to bring in and out it's so cool it's
like Skype Border Patrol sounds cool I
should do that someday we went into this
seaplane in Vancouver
and we flew over all of these islands
and I started to realize that while it
works to draw these really straight
lines in like the middle of Canada when
you get to the east and the west coast
in the Canada region you start to get a
lot of little islands lots of water
weaving in out of islands cutting them
all up and that's hard to draw lines
through luckily on the west coast they
were able to not stick with the 49th
parallel which would have cut Vancouver
Island just in a weird place they dipped
it down and whatever but over on the
east side they didn't do that and you
end up with this line this is Canada but
the only way to get into Canada from
here is through this land bridge that
goes through the United States kind of
weird probably not that big of a deal
fact none of these are actually a big
deal like they're all like kind of goofy
weird things but they don't actually
cause like too much inconvenience
although the high schooler is having to
go like through four border crossings
every day is actually pretty weird and a
huge inconvenience so I take back what I
just said so it was a great weekend in
Vancouver I loved hanging out with these
wonderful people and I learned a little
something about this big straight line
that I didn't know anything about and it
confirmed to me something that I've
learned time and time again which is
some lines on the map look really simple
and like they just look like straight
lines but you zoom in enough you'll
always find weird stuff so it's always
interesting to zoom in that's I guess
the moral of the story anyway thanks for
watching
[Music]
all right I'm gonna do an ad now about
something that I care a lot about which
is audible I listen to a lot of audible
and I have since 2011 at this giant
library of now hundreds of books that
really have changed my world since I'm
able to read a lot more I dyslexic so
reading is like a difficult thing for me
and now I listen to books and it really
has changed my life I know it sounds
like dramatic but it's actually true but
I'm not gonna go into it anymore
audible is a giant repository of like
more audiobooks than any other library
in the world it's really great if you
sign up with audible you get a free book
every month one of my favorite parts
about audible is if you start a book and
it's not for you you can like easily
exchange it and return it and get a new
one plus two audible originals which is
like their original content that you can
choose two of every month for people who
go to audible.com slash Johnny Harris
Joh and NY har R is you get a book for
free you get a month free of this a book
and two pieces of content for free zero
money you can try it out see if you like
it you can either go to that URL
audible.com slash Johnny Harris or you
can text Johnny Harris with no spaces -
500 500 and it'll send you a link one
that I just finished is sapiens which
completely changed my entire perspective
on the planet and the history of
humanity fantastic book you should check
it out so audible.com slash Johnny
Harris or you can text Johnny Harris -
500 500 and you will get a free month of
audible which is a free book and two of
these originals killer deal - no brainer
for me that's why I work with audible
because I believe in it so thank you for
watching and thank you audible for
sponsoring this video have a good day